11h en ce samedi ensoleillé du mois de
juillet 134 personnes sont venues
embarqué opecst pour cette croisière
pique nique sur la scène une bonne
dizaine d'années qu'on organise ses
croisières sur la seine
c'est avec dès que le beau temps arrive
les gens se précipitent sur ces
croisières c'est un moment agréable sur
la seine à bord du thier vanot les
passagers présents pour la plupart en
famille partent sur les traces des
peintres impressionnistes
on connaît pas bien les îles qui sont
qui sont au milieu de la scène souvent
on passe devant sur la nationale 13 en
voiture mais on va jamais au plus proche
pardon de la navigation découvre
aujourd'hui un certain nombre de
bâtiments et de lieux qui ont été très
fréquentés un deuxième moitié du 19e
siècle alors surtout par des ses auteurs
des écrivains célèbres comme maupassant
ou essentiellement par des peintres sur
peau puisque c'est ici dans cet
environnement qu'est née
l'impressionnisme notamment avec des
poils qui ont été réalisés par monet et
renoir y changeait plus sainement les
ponts supérieurs et inférieurs du bateau
affiche complet pour la croisière un
voyage sur l'eau qui emmène les
participants le long des îles de la
scène de chatou à maisons laffitte
on était très curieux on se rend compte
de tout les différents endroits assez
insolites parfois
très sympa
après trois heures de quiétude à la
rencontre des peintres et auteur du 19e
siècle
l'heure est au débarquement est au bilan
ce sont des passagers plutôt relax et
que nous retrouvons super intéressant
vraiment un pli guide était nous a
appris plein de choses donc non vraiment
bien c'était très agréable balade assez
surprenante de détente en famille tout
au long de l'été c'est une quinzaine de
croisière qui est proposée sur la scène
des traversées calme et commentée comme
celle d'aujourd'hui ou d'autres plus
festive au son du jazz